>>Ameer: Managing game play is just
like managing other learning
activities in your classroom.
You'll know you're on the right track
when you see your students
helping each other, having fun,
and reflecting on what they're learning.
>>Teacher: So mark it first, good, good.
>>Student: So I get one, nine, so
yellow gets one and I get one number,
it's only the mushroom, so I only
have one oh, that's the nine.
>>So you got those.
>>Teacher: Who's the game master?
>>Student: I am.
>>Teacher: Okay, then Cole, you
shouldn't even be doing this.
>>Ameer: So how do you manage game play?
Step one, think about how
you manage your classroom.
A game isn't some sort of
special zone where anything goes.
Before using a game, think about rules
and procedures you already
have in your classroom.
Leverage those to manage game play.
For example, what are your rules
for cleanup after an activity?
Review those rules with your
students and apply them here.
Step two, everyone plays a role.
Depending on the type
of game you're using,
you may want to create student roles.
One role may be a material
manager who hands out,
organizes and collects game pieces.
Other roles could be a time
keeper, note taker or scorekeeper.
Step one, be a facilitator
not a firefighter.
Even if the answer to a question is a
simple yes or no, guide your students
to discover the answer on their own,
and if several students have the
same question, stop game play
and have a quick class
discussion about that question.
Step two, iterate and improvise.
If there's a common concern that
develops, go ahead and make changes
to the game right then and there.
Who knows, you might create
a unique game that opens
up new learning for your students.
Step three, be a cheerleader.
Support students in their
learning through game play.
Keep an eye out for great moves or
successful strategies that occur
and share them with the class.
Step four, wrap it up.
Plan ahead for the possibility that your
students might not fully finish the game
by the end of class, so make sure you're
clear on how you'll return to the game.
Gather feedback.
For example, ask your students what they
learned from the game, what they liked
and disliked, and what they
might change about the game.
Thanks for watching.
Now go ahead and try
it in your classroom.
Next, to learn how to assess student
learning during and after game play,
check out the video on game assessment.